First of all,
we just want to thank everyone for coming.
We're super excited to share our story with you all.
Um,
so thanks for taking the time.
w what we want to talk about today is I'm just sort of a history of night shift
brewing through the lens of what we have just called create better.
Um,
we've sort of refined what our company stands for,
uh,
to the point of calling this a or calling it create better,
which has led us to sort of consistently improve our business.
Um,
it's kind of about learning from our failures and we're just kind of hoping to
walk through our history,
um,
with that lens in mind and just kind of talk through our story.
So a little bit about who we are.
Um,
we are the three founders of night shift brewing.
Uh,
I'm Michael,
this is Mike.
That's rob.
Um,
we collectively owned about 80% of the company,
so we,
uh,
we're the board of directors.
We make the decisions,
we set the vision for it,
uh,
and we started it.
So we're actively involved day to day.
Um,
and we're also driving sort of longterm vision.
I just want to note,
rob is also the president of the mass brewer's guild,
which has been really impactful not just for our business but also for
businesses,
breweries in Massachusetts.
So that's been super exciting.
So first I want to talk about failure because our past is full of it and I think
it's important context to set.
This is me.
I think just transferring some beer back in 2013 and totally failing at it.
Um,
so I think it was important to note is,
you know,
our failures are often some of the reasons we've been successful because we've
had to learn from them.
Um,
and it's kind of forced us to make creative mistakes.
So I just wanted to walk through a few of them,
um,
and just kind of recap some of the things that we've screwed up over the years
that have taught us some serious lessons.
First off,
we just didn't have any professional experience.
We made a lot of mistakes because we weren't in the industry,
uh,
beforehand we were just home brewers.
Um,
I,
I do think having that perspective kind of gave us this fresh set of eyes on the
industry and sometimes I think we made more creative decisions,
but also a lot of mistakes.
Um,
you know,
at,
at times,
especially in the early years,
the quality of our beer was sometimes iffy.
Uh,
it was good enough definitely to get us where we are.
But,
um,
you know,
we did have corks that would pop out of bottles,
bottles,
that would,
gosh,
there's a video on youtube of a guy opening a bottle of our beer and it like
explodes everywhere.
Um,
which we play at staff parties.
and we've drained a lot of beer.
Uh,
we won't put out beer that's no good or that's good or that's no good.
Um,
and it's,
uh,
it's forced us to develop a much better lab,
better equipment.
And we learned a lot through,
um,
you know,
initially having some,
if you be here,
um,
inventory and freshness issues were,
uh,
definitely things we have struggled with or at least struggle with in the past.
Um,
as you grow,
you know,
you have more and more beer and you have to figure out how to store it and how
to keep track of it.
Um,
so we've had to learn ways to sort of deal with that and develop cold storage
and a better processes for managing all of our beer.
Um,
especially early.
We barely make payroll a lot and it was really scary.
Um,
but that forced us to create a more fiscally responsible approaches,
uh,
to our budget,
and have a better control of our balance sheet.
Um,
when we started it was just the three of us and we didn't really have a staff
development plan cause we were worried about developing anyone other than
ourselves.
Um,
we're now at 126 people and that has forced us to think about,
you know,
how we're developing people and their future is not just our own.
Um,
and we most recently hired an HR director,
which was super exciting.
Um,
and then just finally,
uh,
you know,
under planned over budget and abandoned projects,
you've got plenty of those behind us.
Um,
but I,
I think what's important to note there is,
you know,
we just learned to ask better questions to put better projects in front of us.
Um,
all right,
so why are we hope you're going to listen to us anyway.
Um,
we're a passion driven business.
We started with a really strong passion and I think we still have that today.
It's what drives us to,
you know,
wake up everyday and do what we do.
Um,
we're still very independent,
you know,
we own collectively 80% of the company.
The rest is friends and family.
Um,
we've been profitable every year since we started 150 times volume growth since
the very beginning.
Um,
I,
you know,
it's been amazing to see and we don't even think about it very often.
We just kind of keep going.
But,
um,
we do,
we sort of do have that behind us and it's been awesome.
Um,
like I said,
we employ 126 people.
We try and offer them great perks.
Um,
we started with this approach of,
you know,
going deep,
not wide,
and we,
we still have maintained that,
um,
in our market,
uh,
we are just in Massachusetts when we started and we're mostly still in
Massachusetts today.
Uh,
just a little bit out of state.
we still have strong sales and velocity and as we're going to talk about today,
we're on a mission to shift our industry and create better.
So a little a visual history of night shift through the lens of create better,
um,
five years of homebrew behind us.
We started in 2012.
Uh,
we had 150 capital raised between friends and family,
three staff,
1500 square feet and Everett,
I'm in this small dingy little construction space.
Um,
and that we turned into a brewery and a lots of passion,
lots more ignorance.
Um,
this photo was taken at 4:36 AM at the end of a really long brew day.
That was our first day ever brewing.
Um,
so it's just like one of those moments we've captured first day Berean
commercially,
first day ruined commercially.
Yes,
true.
And here's a day a brewing,
um,
as homebrewers.
So this isn't our Somerville Kitchen.
Um,
three of us just standing there looking like muppets.
And,
um,
then we turned pro and that shot was taken,
uh,
for the improper Bostonian.
Uh,
in 2012.
This is our brewery back in 2012.
This is like a clean day for us.
Um,
yeah,
so I just want to talk through a few of the,
uh,
the things that we focused on,
to sort of create better when we were beginning.
And then I'll hand it off to these guys to walk us through the rest of the
years.
We started with all cork and cage bottles.
We hand labeled them,
we hand wrote on them.
We were really going for like a very premium look.
We were trying to stand out in the marketplace,
um,
elevate beer to sort of like a wine like status.
Uh,
it gave us higher margins and um,
I think it did help us stand out.
Um,
and it,
you know,
a personal touch like writing on every single label.
It was a huge pain,
but like people I think appreciated it.
Um,
and eventually we moved away from that into cans,
which we'll get to fairly soon.
Uh,
but it was an interesting way to start because it was this create better
mentality.
Um,
I also just want to know what we started with volunteers.
Some of those guys in the picture,
there were just volunteers helping us.
Um,
none of them we employ any more,
but we did hire a bunch of our volunteers from the beginning.
Uh,
and that's just been like super rewarding to be able to take people that were
volunteering and just lending their time to us and bringing them on and sort of
help grow the company with them together.
So the other,
I would say like big thing that helped us stand out in the beginning,
it was a hundred percent shifted beers.
It was like nothing can go in a bottle unless it's shifted.
Um,
we even said we will never be an IPA.
That's a thing.
Um,
which is so weird because now like our focus is really like hoppy beers.
but in the beginning it was all shifted.
A Viva Habanero was a,
the Riaa with Habanero peppers.
That was sort of one of our trademark flagship core beers in the beginning.
Um,
it got us attention.
It really established us as an innovation brand.
Um,
ultimately was unsuccessful just because we decided to switch to more drinkable
beers,
hoppy,
hoppy beers,
uh,
that encouraged more repeat purchases.
Um,
genius.
It's genius,
it's brilliant,
but it was a great way to get our name out there and spread the word just to our
barrel aging program that we started with.
Um,
it's still alive to this day.
it,
it was sort of an extension of our shifted approach.
Um,
I mean,
we still produce every Weiss shifted is basically a no traditional,
not,
not just traditional ingredients of water,
malts,
hops and yeast.
So,
um,
anything else that we could think of like cinnamon sticks,
fruit,
Habanero peppers.
We've got weirder than that,
but yeah,
you know,
every is a beard that actually stuck around and we started with it.
Um,
and that one's grown into sort of a core offering of ours.
and I think,
you know,
trying to do barrel aged sour beers,
again forced us to sort of learn about interesting processes that are really
complex and we made a ton of mistakes along the way and now we can,
you know,
put out this,
this awesome sour program.
Um,
that's grown with us.
Uh,
we started with plastic for mentors,
um,
who was not a good idea,
uh,
looking back,
but it was cheap and we didn't have a lot of money so,
uh,
it's so like shameful to say it,
but we had like a,
like a normal ale room which was just conditioned with a air conditioner and
then like a sour stays on room,
which was just a space heater.
And that's how we like controlled temperature,
um,
which is not recommended at all,
but we made it work.
Uh,
and you know,
the beer quality was good enough to get us out there.
Uh,
we did ultimately make the decision to move to stainless steel,
uh,
when we could afford it.
Um,
and you know,
that that allowed us to really expand our style offerings.
It actually allowed us to really get into hoppy beers,
uh,
improve our quality a lot,
and set the direction for the future of the company.
One of the core decisions I think we made in the beginning was to not sign with
a distributor and just do it all ourselves.
Uh,
we'll get to it a lot more later.
But,
uh,
at that time,
you know,
we were just looking at the distributor partners out there.
We didn't see,
um,
anyone that we wanted to work with and a massive franchise law basically locks
you in a contract for life.
So we didn't want to do that.
And so we said,
we'll just throw beer in a Subaru,
drop it off,
and uh,
handle all the sales ourselves.
Um,
it allowed us to keep 30% margin,
which is,
which was good for profitability,
but probably more importantly,
it allowed us to develop really deep relationships with all of our accounts,
um,
and get to know what our customer's needs were and like here on a regular basis.
Um,
and what's happening in the market.
Uh,
our tasting room was not a part of the business plan really.
Um,
and it's become core to who we are today.
we started with 90 square feet.
Uh,
we thought,
you know,
some people will drop in here,
probably not very often because we're in a sketchy warehouse.
Um,
but if they want to come in,
cool.
And,
uh,
we'll sample them on some beers.
Um,
as our reputation grew,
we just got busier and busier.
We expanded our hours.
I think we were just,
um,
is it Thursdays and Saturdays to start?
And it,
you know,
open everyday of the week was soon a thing.
Um,
we've expanded into our production space,
which was like dangerous and not a good idea.
But when you have people like waiting out the door,
what are you going to do?
Um,
and then,
uh,
we ultimately learned like,
okay,
when we move,
which we know we have to do,
we have to build a bigger tap room,
uh,
because this is more important than a 90 square foot space.
And then the last thing I want to talk about is just a,
the decision to put the owl everywhere.
Um,
I actually drew our logo back in 2010 when we were just home brewing and it was
just something to slap on bottles,
uh,
as like our homebrew labels and give it to friends.
Um,
and when we made the business it was just like,
oh,
this is our logo.
Cool.
We decided to be a logo oriented company.
Um,
not a lot of breweries were doing that and we decided like that's going to be
what's everywhere.
Um,
it's a hop and an hour at the same time and it's kind of nocturnal creature.
So it felt like it made sense.
Um,
and we've really,
we've grown with that and we've just made that a bigger,
a bigger part of our branding.
And I think that's been a huge part of sort of how we've grown and created
messaging around our logo in the l transitioning from our early,
early,
early years in 2012 2013 to 2014 and 15 I'll pass it over to Mike.
So the next couple of years,
um,
was a kind of a big transition for us.
Um,
we moved to a new brewery as Michael alluded to.
We went from 700 barrels and 2013 to over 4,000 barrels by the end of 2015,
kind of had a renewed focus on quality of all their branding and you know,
I went through a few expansion projects along the way that,
you know,
themselves had a couple of rough patches that we learned from.
Um,
and then,
you know,
really continue to establish our,
our strong local presence.
And following in 2014,
you know,
we expanded our tap room.
That was a new thing.
It wasn't in our business plan to begin with.
Um,
kind of through that business plan out like,
okay,
we're focusing on the tap room.
It's going to be an awesome place for people to come and hang out instead of
coming to a dingy,
creepy warehouse that didn't have true working bathrooms.
Um,
so this was a very nice upgrade.
Real bathrooms included.
Okay.
Um,
just kind of a side by side.
Our original brewery,
which is about 60 gallons per kettle there,
um,
to our new brewery,
which required steps to get up to and about 600 barrels per batch.
Um,
so a pretty sizable increase in production size there.
And then,
yeah,
there's a couple of a picture of our labs.
So,
you know,
we also invested a lot in quality because you know,
if we're dumping beer that isn't good enough to go out to the market,
um,
which is good for our reputation but bad for our bottom line.
So we had to do something about that in order to continue making world class
beer.
We invested heavily in our lab and equipment and people to run it,
um,
to make sure that,
you know,
everything from,
the day we're brewing it to the time we practice packaging it is,
you know,
analyze along the line and made sure it's quality and we're going to be able to
ship what we make and be really proud of it at the same time.
So increasing the quality,
consistent consistency there is,
was pretty key.
In addition to that,
you know,
transitioning to cans,
um,
it's kind of two parts there.
One was,
you know,
cans are better for the beer,
they don't let light in.
Um,
they don't let as much oxygen in a,
so it increases the shelf stability.
So that increases the quality of,
of the Br just,
just in the package format change.
We kind of saw early on at the craft beer market was shifting away from bottles,
which goes totally against what we were trying to do with the cork and cage.
But,
um,
that's what people started to buy.
And we latched onto that very early on.
Um,
and you know,
as soon as we did,
we noticed velocity increase.
It increased tremendously.
Uh,
and we think a big part of that was,
you know,
it's Kinda hard to sit down for a night and commit to 25 ounces of,
a 7% beer where it's much easier to snap a can off of a four pack and,
you know,
drink 16 ounces of it and then maybe drink the rest of the four pack if you
want.
But,
but you have options.
And then along with the cans,
uh,
it was an opportunity to kind of,
you know,
reinvision the branding.
Um,
and originally with our logo we kind of had the owl and night shift brewing,
all kind of squished together with a box.
Um,
and this offered an opportunity for us to revisit that and really focus on the
owl.
The owl is going to be everywhere to begin with.
So was like,
why not just make that the prominent thing on the can that they,
al is pretty cool and recognizable.
So we did that and we started with a whirlpool can with,
you know,
just the silver can,
which looks pretty cool and the Morph Canada,
then you can see it evolved into a more playful thing with St Chilean whirlpool.
And along with that,
we shifted away from doing our shifted beers with weird ingredients only.
And our,
uh,
no IPA philosophy to doing IPA is and Pale Ales and Centralia whirlpool has
become our two best selling beers.
So we're not afraid to like change our mindset and get stuck in our ways,
so to speak.
Um,
and a really awesome example of RPA,
uh,
evolution is more of,
um,
it was kind of born out of necessity.
Uh,
we weren't very good at hopcat hop contracting or forecasting what we were going
to sell in the future.
Um,
so we kind of took what we got and morph was a way to do that and we had a
consistent brand but each batch was different from each firm itself.
So we saw an opportunity in that.
It's like,
well we can kind of use this as a test market cause we didn't have a flagship
IPA at the time and we would analyze sales data in the tap room and collect
feedback directly from customers in the tap room.
And you know,
we use that to uh,
turn morph into our flagship IPA,
which is San Tilly.
So we kind of secretly crowd sourced our flagship Ipa.
Um,
and then in 2016 we entered that into the world beer cup and it ended up winning
bronze,
which is pretty awesome validation for that process there.
Continue the evolution towards quality and,
and making things happen.
We go from a keg seat belted into the back of the Subaru.
That's my Subaru.
I still drive.
I drove it here today.
Yeah.
Smells like beer.
Constantly smells like beer.
It's not never going away.
And we upgraded to a sprinter van,
um,
you know,
which helped us increase the amount of beer we could drop per per account,
which,
you know,
increased efficiency.
Um,
and then,
you know,
finally now we have a fleet of,
while we still kind of have a fleet of Subaru's floating around,
but we don't deliver beer in him anymore.
Now we have a fleet of refrigerated box trucks.
So everything is cold from the time we package it to the time we deliver it and
put it on the shelf.
Um,
you know,
just kind of focusing on efficiencies and qualities and making sure that the
beer is the best it can be.
And then in 2016 and 2017,
you know,
new equipment,
of course brewery expansion is happening,
a taproom expansions and continuing to add people.
I'm here.
We've got our taproom expansion,
so this is a,
a new room and ended up making this really cool event space,
um,
with the tap room and what we call the annex.
Um,
which ended up being like an event space for us.
Uh,
continue to add new equipment,
new canning line,
our own canning line.
We were using mobile canner.
Again,
we could focus and do our own quality control on that Katie Lane and not have to
rely on somebody else,
more capacity with bigger tanks,
more efficiencies with more equipment outside grain silos.
We could order it by the truckload instead of by the pallet.
Um,
and you know,
it's always awesome to get validation.
You know,
we always thought we had it.
Um,
we always thought we had great culture,
we had quality beer,
a great beer,
people liked it.
Um,
but to enter these contests and win awards and look at our Yelp reviews,
it's,
it's always good to see that.
And Google reviews.
Yeah.
The best one.
Yeah,
of course.
It's always good to have that kind of like different perspective and outside in,
um,
validation of that.
Okay.
Yeah.
Maybe,
maybe we are doing something right.
Um,
that feels good.
Let's continue to try to try to do something cool.
And along the way we've had to hire more people.
So,
you know,
we had about 65 employees at the end of 2017.
I think we mentioned we have 126 now.
Um,
yeah,
we've had to,
we had struggles,
but we've gotten smarter about how we keep the culture.
We got smarter about how we hire people.
We invested in a program that helps us,
uh,
you know,
looking at people's personalities to make sure that the right fit,
get the right people in the right role,
right people in the right seat of the bus so to speak.
So yeah,
we've gotten,
we've gotten smarter at,
at hiring people over over the years,
continued to add great people,
the team and keep them around with what we provide them with culture and
benefits and whatnot.
During that time,
we also started a distributor ship,
so I'm going to let rob take that away.
Sure.
So in,
uh,
October,
2016,
we launched our own distribution company where we were running out of space in
Everett and,
and we needed a new warehouse and we've been doing it for ourselves and we
thought we were kind of good at it.
So,
um,
we were hearing from a lot of other breweries that they were frustrated with the
same options that we were faced at one point.
And a key tenant to our distribution company was,
even though franchise law exist in the state today,
that we wouldn't hold,
um,
fellow likeminded brewers to that if things weren't working out.
We'll take it professionally and we can part ways and it will be better for both
sides of the part of the fence.
NST has grown significantly over the last year.
Uh,
we started the year with 600 accounts.
We now have 1600 accounts that we serve is,
we pretty much go from Springfield,
uh,
east Hampton Amhurst area all the way out to Martha's vineyard.
Now we've really,
really added a lot of capabilities to our logistics side of our operation.
And not only that,
when we started the distribution company,
we,
we were beer guys,
so let's only sell beer,
um,
which we sell 18 different breweries now will this year we also added on wine
and spirits as well as non alcoholic beverages like cold brew and teas and
things like that.
And we just recently also got our import license.
So one of the things we're going to tackle in 2019 and started importing alcohol
from,
from Europe,
starting with some wines from France.
Um,
but all under the same lens of let's look for small likeminded producers who are
doing something a little bit different,
who have either innovative packaging or cool cool products that are small batch
that that we can really take a hold of and represent.
Well we set out to sell beer for other people and we want to make sure we are
good at it.
We didn't want to,
you know,
make a false promise to these other breweries because they are small people like
us that that put their heart and soul into their businesses.
This is a presentation from one of our key suppliers to steal their brewery out
in normal Illinois.
I visited is very normal.
Um,
they make great sour beers in cans.
Uh,
and we are actually their number one distributor along the East Coast from Maine
to Florida.
We are,
we are their best supplier that moved the most volume.
This is just a fun little slide that we,
we've put together once a kind of show that we want to be more than just a beer
company,
that we want to be a beverage company and then anytime of the day we're selling
something that's awesome.
Uh,
most of these are all low.
The first three non are all locally owned Massachusetts businesses,
which is pretty cool.
And then on the brewing side,
we continue to innovate.
This uh,
beer came to life.
We're pointed today as well.
Uh,
I came to life kind of back in 2016 when the brewers after a hot day of brewing,
wanted something light and refreshing to drink and they were drinking like
Miller high life and stuff.
And it was like eventually we were like,
what,
how are we drinking other people's beer when we have all the equipment to make
that beer?
Um,
and we can probably do it better.
So let's do it for ourselves.
And that's what we did.
Um,
and we did it for a couple of times over the year and a half period,
and then we started testing in the market and people are actually responding to
it.
So we decided with that combined with the,
the feeling that we are getting tired of going out into the market and taking
down breweries,
IPA,
draft lines,
and those are breweries that we like to hang out with that we share similar
problems or challenges and successes with.
It was like,
I love the guys at Jack's Abby.
Why am I taking down their draft line?
Let's go after the guys,
uh,
that we don't like and let's go after the biggest guys.
Uh,
and we're sort of using the term macro nuisance now.
and it's also important to say that the light beer category is the largest
category in beer.
And it's one that for whatever reason,
craft brewers decided that they didn't want to play in that that was anti craft.
And so we sort of fenced off the biggest part of the pool and let the biggest
people when in it.
So why not?
Why not try to be the smallest guy taking,
taking share.
We continue to also change our packaging options.
These beers used to be in 750 milliliter champagne bottles.
We talked about these earlier.
These are sour beers that are fermented with bacteria.
Uh,
we got a separate county lines so that we could put the beer live bacteria into
the finished goods.
That's something atypical of what a lot of the sour beers that are out there in
the market.
Those are usually kettle sours,
which they kind of cook it to kind of almost pasteurize the product.
These are living beers.
Um,
and we also kind of tried to play around with the innovative labeling and we use
really cool photography techniques to kind of showcase and they look very
different from our,
our core lineup.
This summer,
we also opened up to beer gardens along the esplanade that were,
that were pretty fun place.
We have a patio in Everett,
I don't know if he ever been,
but it is basically you're sitting on crappy asphalt,
uh,
in an industrial park and it's not very scenic spot.
So we set out to find the best spot in Boston to drink and we worked really hard
to get this location.
Uh,
it was a wild success.
One of the cool things that we did here too was we could be the most profitable
if we only sold nightshift beer here,
but we,
that wasn't who we are.
Uh,
we want to,
we called it the owl's nest and it was a celebration of night shift Bruin and
our friends.
And so we poured a lot of other people's beer here,
uh,
that we made lower margins on,
but it was important to us.
This is just a fun little slide of kind of our,
our barrel edge production over the last seven years,
uh,
and kind of showcases our rapid growth.
Uh,
we started with 200 barrels in our first year this year.
We'll do a little over 30,000.
Our business plan had that.
If we did 10,000 barrels in 10 years,
we'd be wildly successful and we'd,
we'd probably call it quits.
Uh,
now we don't know where this,
where the,
where the limit is and how far will it go.
But I think one important thing is we've always set out to brew to demand not to
hit a number.
We're not beholding to a VC or private equity where we need to hit certain
targets were brewing,
um,
really slightly behind demand so that we can always have the best product on the
shelf.
Um,
and we're not chasing anything that's not real.
I think,
you know,
all this is,
kind of inside feedback on to how we thought we were creating better.
But I think the real proof is,
will customers recognize that and open up their wallets and pay for the product?
These numbers are Iri data,
which is a syndicated data that's from cash registers.
Stales.
Uh,
this is,
these are all from mass liquor stores.
Um,
one thing that we did to get smarter was actually by data.
Instead of a guests.
So this isn't our internal sales numbers.
Uh,
this is actually what people are ringing up at cash registers and it's not every
single transaction that happens,
but it is indicative of what has happened out in the world.
Um,
and we set out to make,
once we decided to make hoppy beer,
we set out to make the best hoppy beer.
And this chart shows that we actually are the number one hoppy beer provider in
the state of Massachusetts,
which is pretty crazy.
That middle column was velocity.
That's really tells us like if a costs,
how often does a customer pick our beer over other people's beer?
And you can see we're almost at two to one ratio over kind of our next closest
peers,
which is pretty incredible to see.
Our Sour can series is classified as a specialty beer.
It is the number two specialty beer in the market just behind Budweiser.
Amber lager.
I don't know who's drinking that crap,
but uh,
but,
uh,
clearly a lot of people are,
we,
we like those showcase here that our velocity is a lot better than theirs.
We're in just less stores than Budweiser is in,
uh,
if we were in more stores,
we would probably be beating them nightlight.
We set out to be that kind of macro nooses and we released it about 26 weeks
ago.
Uh,
so right now we're basically in the top six of light beers,
which were pretty shocked to see that we're beating out big multi or global
breweries with multimillion dollar advertising campaigns.
Uh,
and that we're actually playing somewhat successfully in this market without
really any advertising budget at all other than Instagram.
So that's been fun.
That to take away mind share.
And some of these guys are down almost as much as we're up.
So we're,
we like to think we're directly stealing from their pie.
If you look at just crappy across all styles in Massachusetts,
we're numbered three right now,
just a few hundred thousand dollars behind Harpoon.
But again,
we're beating out a bunch of national brewers that have much more resources that
have been around much more longer than us.
Um,
this is ranked by velocity again.
So in the state where we are the second fastest beer.
So this,
this helps us a lot in our selling story.
When we go to market.
Uh,
if a liquor store is designed to carry us versus let's say,
you know,
dogfish head,
we'll sell three times more volume than dogfish head wound,
that same store.
And then if you bring in the national brewers or the global brewers,
again,
we are a top 10 brand in the state,
which is pretty incredible.
Uh,
this is again a testament to kind of our deep,
not wide philosophy of really trying to get our brand in front of Massachusetts
consumers and make it just as recognizable as some of these other big beer
brands.
We really only package our beer in 16 ounces,
four packs.
So another way to slice the data set is to look at packaging format.
And if you,
if you take all beer across all global brewers in the,
in the state that play in the liquor stores,
uh,
and look at only 16 ounce four pack sales,
we are by far the dominant.
Um,
I'd like to say the king,
uh,
we're top point Budweiser pretty heavily here and,
and we're,
we're a far market leader compared to our peers in the,
in the state.
Just really,
again,
kind of humbling for us to see that this kind of idea from our Somerville
kitchen is actually like really taken off.
But nonetheless,
we're not done yet.
Uh,
we're,
we're sending out to 2019 to try to create even better.
We're building a Boston tap room.
I love joy wharf right next to the garden.
It will have a brewery in there,
a kitchen and a coffee bar,
which is something called kitchen and coffee bar.
All new for us.
It will really be our innovation factory and a lot of our new ideas will be
first developed there before scaling up and going out to the wholesale world.
Uh,
where again,
continue even better workplace.
Any more benefits,
adding more resources,
adding more internal training.
That's,
that's super important.
We're trying to make ourselves the best place to work,
although I don't know if we can compete with all your amenities,
but we'll try.
Uh,
I think we do have more free beer.
Um,
uh,
we're continuing down that macro nuisance line and we're going to launch
limelight this year,
which is definitely a direct shot at bud light lime we think will be better.
It will use better lime ingredients and a w if it's at all success successful as
nightlight.
We think what we'll have another big winner on her hand.
Um,
we're continuing to invest in production.
We're continuing to add more sour styles.
There'll be a fourth one,
kind of the mix brier,
a ramble wise,
which will be a blackberry sour with lemon.
Uh,
and then the next kind of two big questions for us is,
is what do we,
we sell 90% of our beer in Massachusetts and only a beer that we make.
Can we grow beyond Massachusetts and replicate what we've done in this state and
other states.
With the regulatory environment,
you kind of have to like re invent the wheel in every state.
They all have different liquor laws,
which makes it really confusing and challenging.
But can we replicate the brewery and the tap room experience somewhere else?
And can we also replicate our wholesale,
um,
operation and other states and that those are kind of the two big undertakings
as we look future.
And then the third one is should we do other beverages and take the same sort of
lens of creating better to other beverages?
Could we do it for spirits,
coffee,
wine,
cider,
Kombucha or whatever we are excited and passionate about and uh,
and,
and kind of take the,
what the lessons we've learned from beer and apply it elsewhere.
And I think there are file knows just every day we tried to create better.
And I think you guys do the same and we appreciate your time.
Um,
and we can open up to any questions and answers.
[inaudible]
let me ask you a timely question.
A certain other brewery in the Boston areas having some very widely publicized
labor issues right now.
Um,
seems like they made some pretty appalling cuts to the wages of some workers in
now seem to be like boomerang.
I mean,
way back in the other direction.
Maybe this is just two people who made some bad decisions,
but it seems like the first time that attention has been drawn to the labor
practices of craft brewers.
Uh,
I'm sure you guys are thinking about this a lot.
I'm wondering what the implications might be.
Um,
in terms of,
you know,
like wages in the industry of general employment practices.
How much is this going to have any kind of widespread impact or is it just a
kind of one shot thing that's going to die out
a few days?
Uh,
I mean,
I don't want us to speak to the specific situation of the brewery or referencing
too,
but the traditionally the beer industry hasn't been one that's been a good place
to make a living wage.
Uh,
we've always set out to try to create a place that people should earn an income.
If you ever read through some of my older I use,
I usually banter on beer advocate,
uh,
forums.
Uh,
I've,
I've justified our higher prices,
beers around a pain are people more,
uh,
and the higher cost of doing business in the Boston Metro area.
That's important to us.
Uh,
as the mass brewer's guild,
we are certainly open to doing some sort of compensation studies so that we can
all benchmark how we compare to our peers.
Um,
and,
and make sure that everyone understands like kind of where the market is.
We obviously can't get into the anti competitive territory of price fixing
wages,
but,
uh,
I think there is more that could be done to,
to make sure that everyone's compensated correctly.
I think the three of us never started this to get rich.
That's not our motive.
Um,
and we've always felt that we should say share the success with the people who
create it.
Yeah.
Talk a little about packaging.
You talked about going from,
from a seven corked and caged,
seven fifties to cans.
Why'd you end up on the 16 ounce cans?
I know it's what everyone is doing,
but why 16 not 12 I personally find 16 to be kind of more than I usually want.
It's definitely something we went back and forth on.
I mean,
we showed a picture of where we first did do twelves and the kind of initial
feedback was that it would be cooler if they were in tall boys.
And,
uh,
I,
I would certainly credit a lot of that to the alchemists and heady topper.
I feel like they kind of like pave the way of like,
this is where the cool kids go.
Uh,
but I do agree,
we do make nightlight in 12 ounces,
which is our first kind of return back to the 12 ounce.
And uh,
for the first like three or four months to 16 ounces where king,
but now the 12 ounces are,
are kind of taking over as far as the preferred a package type.
And it,
we're definitely now considering should we move other beers into either both
formats or are back down to 12 about like the 9% ones in 12 hours.
I agree with you.
That's a little much for me to,
um,
I also just want to add,
like it seems that the 16 ounce format,
um,
is somewhat of a new England phenomenon.
Um,
you know,
you go,
you venture outside of New England and it is,
you know,
you still see a lot of 12 ounce bottles,
you see a lot of 12 ounce cans.
Um,
so,
and one of the other aspects was,
okay,
we use the same amount of volume in the same amount of time to fill bigger
format.
It's,
it's cost us less in the long run.
it's slightly small.
Um,
but a bunch of those things combined kind of,
you know,
let us to this to be like,
okay,
we need to compete in this market.
16 ounces or New England phenomenon,
let's,
let's at least play around with it
data wise too.
We have some of our distro brewery partners that sent those 12 ounce cans and
they didn't sell very well and we asked them,
can you put them in sixteens and we'll see if it sells better.
And some of them did do that for us and the 16th did sell better,
which is,
it was just kind of crazy.
Um,
the,
especially ones from out of state where like,
well everyone wants 12 in our market,
white,
we're not going to make something special for you guys.
But when the velocity increased,
it was worth it.
So with like the craft beer scene growing so much,
has that changed?
I guess the way you guys look at what you're doing.
So I'm sure when he out it wasn't as
big of a,
of a fad,
but nowadays you see different places popping up all over the place,
which is great for the consumer.
But I just wonder if it changes the way you look at things at all.
And also,
do you have any other favorite um,
non night shift fears?
Sure.
I'll start this one.
Um,
I mean one of the brewers we consistently look up to is Allagash.
there,
you know,
that beautiful branding,
uh,
incredible beer,
great leadership,
um,
really good QA QC program.
Uh,
they seem to sort of check all the boxes in terms of like excellent brewery.
And so they've sort of become like a great model and staple for us.
Uh,
in terms of how we look at the industry.
I mean,
I think rob kind of touched upon it earlier,
but I do think,
you know,
if you look at overall industry tent trends,
bureau is somewhat flat.
Um,
we're,
we're not.
Um,
and so we definitely feel like we can continue competing and growing and
innovating on the brewery perspective and,
um,
you know,
adding a tap room allows us to connect with consumers,
uh,
you know,
sort of in our space.
Um,
so doing that in Boston,
um,
it was just sort of building on the,
the tap room success that we've had,
uh,
and sort of diversifying our portfolio between wholesale involvement and sort of
on premise taproom involvement.
Um,
but looking into other beverages,
um,
is is something that we consistently or have consistently talked about.
But,
uh,
it started to become a more and more real conversation,
as we look at like,
what is the future for,
you know,
not just night shift brewing but like night shift the family.
So when you guys do
collaborative,
uh,
beers,
how do you decide where the beer is brewed?
That's a good question.
Um,
I don't know if I know the answer to that to be honest.
Uh,
I think it usually depends.
Sometimes we coordinated around travel,
whether it's somebody's going on vacation or somebody is coming for like extreme
beer fest by beer advocate.
Hey,
um,
you know,
why don't you come a day earlier and we'll hang out.
A lot of those collaborations are really a great opportunity for brewers swap,
like inside,
you know,
techniques and methods and processes.
That is kind of the real secret value behind those.
There are of course really fun and it's fun to kind of mash up the either the
styles that breweries are known for or their label art and stuff like that.
And,
and we do a fair amount of them,
but they're definitely not big revenue generators for us.
For us.
I would also say a lot of the collaborations that we've done,
uh,
I've kind of gone back and forth.
It's kind of like a serial collaboration,
if you will.
Uh,
so one time we'll do a collaboration at night shift and then we'll sell that
beer,
you know,
through our tap room.
And then the next time we'll traveled with APP or into a collaboration over
there with them so they get a chance to sell that beer through their tap room
and things like that.
So,
um,
it's a true collaboration.
I wanted to ask about,
uh,
the new flavor process.
So like now that it's not just three of you working on,
you know,
let's throw this in there and see what happens.
You mentioned you have a new blackberry coming out I think was how many people
are involved with that or how do you decide on the recipe?
How do you kind of push that to market?
We used to be involved in every single recipe because it was ours.
I mean,
I think when we launched,
like every single one was in a notebook somewhere that we had home brewed a
bunch and we sort of brought it to market and watched it evolve.
Um,
but you know,
as we've hired a team and when we have people that can make beer that's way
better than any of us could.
So,
um,
we didn't trust our people.
Uh,
we,
we definitely have input on sort of like,
where do we want division or where do we see the company going from a vision
perspective of like,
all right,
we want to get more into sour.
So like,
let's develop those recipes and um,
sort of set that direction.
But like our team of our production team,
which is actually don't it,
what's the size in terms of staff?
I think it's like a dozen plus people.
Okay.
Yeah.
So I was gonna say like 15 people,
they crush it every single day.
And so we trust them to,
to nail it,
execute,
innovate.
Um,
you know,
we,
we sort of have like our wholesale market beers and then we have like our tap
room beers.
Um,
and we've actually kind of blended a little bit over the last year and putting
more small batch stuff out into the market.
Um,
but we see a lot of our innovation happen with those smaller batch releases.
We have smaller tanks that are basically exclusively reserved for that.
And then the brewers are basically just given like,
you know,
freewill.
They're just come up with whatever you think is interesting and cool,
put it out,
see how it performs,
and then we scale up appropriately based on success,
feedback,
all that stuff.
Um,
it's,
it's a really fun,
creative process and again,
like our team is trusted to do it and we just kind of sit back and go like,
awesome.
That's the direction.
And keep going.
I'm curious about your new light beer offering.
Um,
I'm curious why no other craft breweries are very few other craft breweries seem
to be going down this road.
And I'm also curious like what the different challenges are as far as both
technically brewing and marketing,
this kind of very different offering.
I think that there is a couple of reasons.
Um,
you know,
there are a few craft breweries doing it.
Um,
there are,
you know,
some of them are the,
the bigger craft breweries.
And I think part of the reason for that is it's kind of a daunting task because
the market is pretty much cornered by like bud light,
Miller light.
Um,
so,
you know,
they've already kind of got a huge head start on that and it's hard to kind of
break into that.
Um,
you know,
we,
we had success and got lucky with our branding and um,
you know,
it's kind of something that people I think we're looking for.
But I think that's one of the,
one of the bigger reasons for that.
Um,
that coupled with they demand a lower price point.
you know,
people go out and they buy a light beer that's you know,
4%.
Um,
they don't expect to pay 15,
$16 for,
you know,
a four pack that they expect to pay a lot less per 12 ounce 12 pack.
Um,
so you know,
that,
that's part of it too because a lot of other craft breweries including,
and that's one
of the reasons why we held off on actually going full force into it for,
for awhile.
It was because you know,
it,
it is lower margins.
Um,
and it's a tougher beer to brew.
There's not much other flavored hide behind if you,
if you don't brew it right or don't have great quality control and things like
that.
So it kind of all those things combined.
I mean,
I can't speak for any other brewery really,
but I would assume that those are all big reasons for not for them not really
entering that market.
And I'll just add this data only chose two PAC tights.
Bud lite is packaged in like so many different class bottles,
18 packs,
24 packs,
30 packs,
uh,
that if you look at that number,
that's almost 9 million here,
I think it's in 26 weeks.
It's something like almost 50 million.
So while we're making a dent,
we're,
we're nowhere near the Goliath that is bud light.
Um,
that,
that beer is going down every year.
They're selling less and less of it,
but,
uh,
it's a big hurdle to attack.
It's something like,
I think 40% of the beer drank and the state is bud light,
which is ridiculous.
I just want to add one thing based on your question,
right?
I think we've almost put it in like our breweries DNA to ask questions like what
you just asked,
which is like,
why isn't anyone doing?
Like,
why aren't more people doing that?
And like if that question gets asked her on the brewery and we can't come up
with a good answer,
it's just like,
okay,
go there,
like go in that direction.
That's really interesting and at least explore.
Um,
and that's Kinda what we're trying to do.
And it's a similar thing to start your own distribution company.
Everyone told her last night,
it's way too hard.
You guys can't figure it out.
Brewers can't just run a distribution company.
There's guys who's done this for decades.
Jen multigeneration businesses that are billion dollar revenues,
just give it to them.
They'll get it there.
And it was like,
no,
we're going to try and do it ourselves.
So I'm going to do a better than you.
Right.
We don't always do it better,
but we try.
Uh,
thanks for really good beer of the ears.
Um,
can you talk about your improvement process after you release a beer?
Uh,
I swear that a whirlpool has got one more bitter over the years.
So I'm curious like once he released a beer,
do you actually go back and look at it and like try and improve the recipe or do
you try and keep it as consistent as possible?
I would say there's always a little bit of evolution in the beers as,
as they,
as time goes by as the brewers tweak them,
uh,
and try to get them better and better.
Uh,
obviously taste is subjective and not all the times it is better.
the other component I'll add is that it is an agricultural product at the end of
the day.
Mosaic hopps from year to year do not always taste the same,
which is a challenge.
And we,
and that's some of the tweaking is derived from that,
uh,
around,
crop variability.
Uh,
but we do have a,
uh,
a tasting program where different versions of whirlpool or tasted a against
benchmark batches versus how they're aging on shelves.
And if product is skewing out of what everyone teams is whirlpool,
then then we reevaluate what went wrong or what changed and,
and things like that.
Um,
but it,
it's definitely hard to keep it as consistent.
So,
I mean,
for all the shinny on Bud light,
I've done,
uh,
they do an amazing job of getting that right.
Uh,
and that's something that we can't quite compete with,
but we try our best and we do have Qa QC processes in a,
in line to try to mitigate any,
any drift.
Thanks everyone.
[inaudible].